[Music]
now how does it feel to say fiance yeah
engagement looks good on bachelor nation
stars Jared Haven and Ashley Iook
kinetic Jared popped the question last
month in where else paradise so when did
you figure out I'm gonna propose in
paradise I mean it's happened fast but
the difference between Ashley myself and
any other engaged couple from bachelors
that we've known each other for three
years before I got on one knee and so
when we got together we knew that it was
more than just boyfriend/girlfriend we
knew this was marriage material lifelong
relationship type stuff and so I knew
probably about a little over a month
before I was paradise that I was gonna
get down on one day and people kept
asking me are you nervous are you
nervous and I said yeah I'm nervous but
more anxious than all honesty because it
already felt like we were engaged to
certain things yeah when we came out
everybody was like congratulations just
moving from girlfriend but thank you so
much really appreciate it when people
would be like you know like how's it
who's your boyfriend or whatever I'd be
like well he's my boyfriend mode like we
talked about kids and marriage and all
that like it doesn't really do it
justice because it's somebody I've known
and have such a close relation to for
three years
yep we were just boyfriend and
girlfriend without touching I will say
it's cool that with The Bachelor they're
getting their first story that really
evolved outside the show and they're
getting a friendship story and they've
never really had that where they have
two people who it never worked out
on-screen with then somehow it's not
gonna work the show has a history some
some couples have not made it does that
make you guys think hey what we really
developed here was this friendship and
we use the show in that way and so we're
really this true love story I mean we
met on the show yeah I mean the reason
I'm with Ashley is because of Bachelor
Paradise and that's something that I'll
never
get or take for granted do I think our
foundation is stronger than most couples
coming out of the show definitely I
would absolutely great yeah we're not
gonna have to go through that weird
period we're readjusting in real life
yeah we've just been adjusted for a long
time a lot of tit couples come off the
show and that's when they really start
dating because then they're real life
and where do they live and who's moving
and you know do our families like each
other so on and so forth where that's
already been established with us for a
very long time and so we've built this
very strong foundation on everything
that's happened and here we are the
bachelor pebble you know it's so
romanticize it's like a big fairy tale
that when you leave it it's like
bursting the bubble and you're like whoa
real life do I like you in realize yeah
we're the helicopters and the roses
what's going on
yeah our dates are just like the movies
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]